- All right, everybody
let's get to my first guest.
She is not only a beautiful singer,
but also a beautiful person.
We have watched her grow up
from a Disney Channel star
to the strong woman she is today.
She's had nine top 20
songs and has been named
one of time's most influential
people, super cool!
You can see her starting tomorrow,
flexing her acting skills once again,
in Eurovision Song Contest,
"The Story of Fire Saga," on Netflix,
it's an amazing film, it's awesome.
She's the one and only Demi Lavato.
Hey, what's up Demi, can you hear me?
- Yeah, I can hear you.
- Oh, good, oh good.
How are you doing?
- I'm so good, how are you?
- I'm doing all right.
What have you been doing in quarantine?
Everybody's got a kind of
a different thing going on.
Mine has been filled with kids
and trying to entertain them like a clown.
What is your life like? (chuckles)
- Mine is taking care of my dogs,
my fur babies.
So they're my kids and,
yeah, just spending a
ton of time with them.
I actually picked up some like
good habits in quarantine,
which were like--
- Oh!
- Journaling, I never
used to journal before,
and I picked up journaling,
I picked up yoga,
which I always hated until now,
and it's what I needed.
And it was the perfect medicine
for perfect time in my life,
and, I couldn't be more grateful.
- No, I agree.
I've been having the same thing
and I actually love, I'm
jumping ahead of the interview,
but it's just kind of a nice segue.
I love how open you are
about mental health,
because I have similar issues
and I've suffered from depression.
I think a lot of people,
especially in the creative world,
or just from childhood, you've
been kind of trained to like,
just keep going and you can handle it,
especially as a woman, it's like,
don't let them see you sweat.
I just love that you're open about that
because, not everybody's as vulnerable,
at being like that.
And I think it's helpful for your fans
and 'cause I know in every meet and greet,
you probably get people
saying that I do too.
And they're like,
"Man, thank you for just
like being open in your songs
"and open, with everybody,
"'cause I felt like this was just me
"and like knowing that somebody else
"is going through it
makes you not feel alone
"and so depressed about it."
So thank you for doing that.
It's really hard.
- I just have to say
that, you were like the first idol
that I ever had and--
- You're so sweet.
- I wouldn't be the
artist or even the person
that I am with being so outspoken
and vulnerable and fearless
if I hadn't had you to look up to.
So I thank you for that,
because--
- Very nice.
- Yes. I just, like,
I looked at you as my idol growing up,
you are fearless and
courageous and real as,
and I love that about you
and I've always just thought to myself,
like when I was younger,
I always thought to myself,
"If I ever make it, I wanna be like her,
"because she's real and she's genuine."
- And I think the thing about it though,
is even you're saying like,
"You're strong, you're courageous,
you're all those things,"
I'm not all the time, it takes work.
Like, that's the thing,
I think everybody looks at us as like,
like even when you overcome
something, they're like,
"Okay, well she's already overcome,"
then I'm like, "No, no,
no, that's a daily effort."
And like trying to be
positive, that's a daily effort
and that's not like a given,
like you're just over it,
you went to some magical
therapy session and it's over.
I think that that's a daily
thing that you work at
and a daily thing that I work at,
and I don't know.
I just thank you for the compliments,
but I just think it's really,
it's a really cool thing
and it's not easy to always
have a spotlight on you
and arrows being aimed at you,
especially when you are vulnerable
and you give people more ammo
for all the stories out there.
So anyway, but thank you for doing that.
I love, and I don't even know
if you saw me tweet about,
I was jamming so hard to your new single.
I love it.
- Aw, thank you Kelly so much.
- I love it!
I think it's such a,
it's like refreshing
whenever you hear a song too,
and you haven't heard it saying like that,
you haven't heard the message
kind of twisted like that.
And I was like, "Whoa!"
I was like, "That was a
really powerful message,
"but cleverly done."
And I'm telling you what,
Jedi Level Sabotage, (both chuckle)
is legit, my favorite lyric
I've heard in a very long time,
what inspired this song?
Is it just your life
and kind of just really daily
kind of figuring out you?
- Yes.
I actually wrote that song last summer
and recorded it last summer.
And I did it with my producer Oak Felder,
who I did "Sorry Not Sorry"
with and a bunch of other songs.
- I love him, he's great!
- Yes, he's so great.
You know he's obsessed with Star Wars.
So he had this Star Wars
memorabilia in his studio,
and he came up with that
lyric and I was like,
"Oh, that's genius.
"We gotta put that in there."
But yeah, I just like the message,
I felt like I wasn't
being authentic to people
because I've been editing pictures.
Like, I had gone on a vacation
to Bora Bora last year
and I edited the bikini
pictures and I posted them
and I got a bunch of likes,
but it didn't feel good
because I was putting up
something that wasn't real.
I felt like I was catfishing everybody.
- But at some point you probably felt
the need to do that because
everybody does that.
And like, if you do come out looking real,
it's like, people don't even know
what that's supposed to look like anymore.
- Yes, it's like teenagers.
I wouldn't be surprised if
they didn't know what cellulite
or stretch marks look like
until they pop up on their body,
and then all of a sudden they have
to face students out of their pictures
because I'm doing it,
and they see me doing.
So I was like, "No, I need to change this.
"I need to change the narrative,
"I need to like post something real."
And so I posted something
while I was like in the studio
and it was that unedited bikini picture.
And it just felt so good
because I had a few crushes at the time,
and it was interesting to see
that all of those crushes,
they actually liked that picture
where all of cellulite was out
and I wasn't touched up and I was like,
"Oh my gosh!"
Like, here's these people
I was trying to impress,
they were the ones I
was trying to impress,
not people like fans or anything,
I know that they accept
me and love me for me,
but, I was trying to
look hot for my crushes.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then they--
- At some point it's like,
well, they're gonna see ya',
eventually.
- Exactly
and I don't want them to like,
think I'm catfishing them.
- Yeah.
- Anyways, I felt that
was like the first step
in kind of owning, taking the power back
from what other people were placing,
the judgments people
were placing on my body,
I got to take the power back and be like,
"Okay, you really wanna judge me here?
"Here it is."
- Yeah.
- Nothing that you say is going to affect
what the strength and the love
that I have for myself up here.
So come out clean.
- I feel like it's really freeing
'cause we're both women in an industry
that is hard on women and harder on women.
All right, so Demi,
you've been very vocal,
which I appreciate because
we have gigantic platforms
that I think we should use.
But you've been pretty vocal
about "Black Lives Matter."
So, what do you think personally,
that we can all do differently?
- I think the first step
is educating ourselves.
We have a lot of time
on our hands right now.
There is no reason why
we shouldn't be watching these movies,
watching and absorbing in all information
that we possibly can about
what's going on in the world.
And then, from there,
we've seen it all over the
media, that being silent
and being not racist
is not enough anymore.
And, that's kind of
something that I posted,
posted about, like a month ago
when the Arbery robbery stuff happened,
I was like,
I saw online what had happened
and I felt this overwhelming sense of like
frustration, anger, I was like crying
and I started writing in my phone.
I just got to all my emotions
and I felt guilty that
I hadn't been doing more
and saying more, as an ally.
But I was also afraid,
that people were going to come at me.
- Cause they will.
- Yes, because everybody's
angry right now,
and I just didn't want anyone to think
that I had the wrong intentions
or that I was uneducated.
Like, speaking about something
that I didn't know about,
that was a fear of mine.
And so I kind of, when that happened,
and even before I found
out about George Floyd,
I was like, "No, I need to do more,
"I need to be an ally,
"I have not been an ally."
I have like Aretha Franklin,
Billie Holiday, Whitney Houston
these women of color have
like shaped my musical journey
and how am I supposed
appreciate what they've given me
and not stand out for their community.
And so I just, I switched my thinking
and then all of this happened and,
I wish I had kind of come
to that realization sooner,
but I think everything
happens in its own timing,
and I've now gotten to a place where like,
because I'm able to deal with
my own demons, my own things,
I can now kind of help,
advocate for other people.
And I think maybe that's a reason why
some people aren't speaking out
and doing things is they're afraid,
but they're also like not
ready to help other people.
I dunno, I just wanted to be the ally
that I know I can be,
and, I want to be able
to shift the thinking
as much as possible because,
the legacy that I will leave as a person
will last so much longer than the music
that we leave behind.
- Yeah, totally.
Your character means everything.
I agree.